our next speaker is a PhD dropout
I hear a lot of people saying like
genius right
other people being so sad but people who
know genius right but his life took a
turn after he quit his PhD he became a
Segway tour guide on the National Mall
and he would like to apologize to all of
you for that right now
please welcome actually more so than I
even one of the organizers of the DC
data Community groups who's going to
become much more active in the next year
right right pinky swear
all right Mark is gonna make you yes
we're gonna hold you to it
oh I'm actually scared of Tommy for this
threat so so with that please welcome
Alex
great thanks so much Jared for having me
thanks so much everybody for uh for
being here my name is Alex
um I'm gonna be talking a little about
code promotion in R
um that's my Twitter handle if you want
to tweet at me
um and just a little about me I lead the
solutions engineering team at the
company formerly known as our studio now
known as posit
um and so my team primarily we occupy
ourselves with is like taking stuff to
production in both R and and python so
in your brains we're going to rewind to
like before David's talk which was great
back to Mark's talk because like these
two talks are really like peas in a pod
so rewind your brain to like oh Mark's
talk was so good he taught me how to
like do code in production it was so
good so this talk is not going to be
about so much about our code it's going
to be sort of about the stuff you do
around your R code
um to get it into production
so uh I know I have lived this life you
probably have lived this life uh you're
a very intimidating boss comes to you
and they're like why is the dashboard
down
this is not good the meeting was today
where we were supposed to look at the
dashboard the dashboard is down uh you
know it's because you made some update
you pushed some change you did something
and you didn't quite check it through
beforehand right so uh what we're going
to talk about today is is code promotion
which is generally sort of the sequence
of things you want to do to put
something into production in a way where
it's protected right so there are sort
of two parts to that and that is being
able to test validate and and sort of
make sure the thing is ready before it
goes up so that's part one and then part
two is making sure it only goes up once
you've done those things right you have
a validation plan and it's it only goes
there once it's validated
um so I will say this is a little bit an
advanced maneuver uh and so I would
suggest you do some other stuff first so
like writing good code is like really
helpful uh and and Mark I think talked a
bunch about that and also had some of
these similar resources
um doing some basic project hygiene
right using projects uh using a
correctly subpath kind of things if you
know the what they forgot to teach you
about our course
um it's it's there using git is good and
using RN probably
um would also be great and and I have
resources here on all these they're on
the slides linked if you want them later
um but okay let's say you've done all
that now you're like ready to go right
we're gonna we're gonna do code
promotion so the first thing you need is
three environments you want to Dev a
test and a prod environment right this
is like pretty pretty you've probably
heard about this before we're gonna get
a little deeper into like how to do it
but like Dev test prod right you're
gonna develop stuff in Dev you're gonna
test it in test and prod is is for
production um I have this little
asterisk sometimes two depending on your
use case you can kind of smush Devon
test together right like those could be
one environment where you do your
development and your testing but prod
should like definitely be its own place
okay so you need three environments
and so how are these environments
different right like so so one big
difference is how easily can you make
changes in each of those environments
right in Devon test and Dev in
particular you want to be able to
iterate quickly you want to be able to
try stuff out prod like no right only
things that have been really validated
go into prod
um additionally right the level of
validation which sort of goes along with
that right and Deb you're going to be
trying things out you're going to be
testing them things might work they
might break they might not work that's
fine it's a Sandbox right you want to be
able to do that there stuff in prod you
want to have it validated you validated
it both for like and right for for data
science you need to validate both for
the uh like empirical correctness of
what you're doing and the like code
quality right that like this is going to
stand up to some sort of scrutiny some
sort of rigor and then the last thing
that comes up a lot is sort of the
realness of the analysis right are you
are you accessing real data or is it
some sort of fake data that that you
have instead because you don't want to
have the real data um in your in your
Dev environment this is especially
important if you're working with pii or
Phi data right you got to think about if
you have a Dev that's great or you can
use real data but it has to be really
sandboxed in that case right so you
can't get anything out
um if you're doing like rights from what
you're doing are you actually like you
probably don't want to be like doing
your testing and accidentally writing to
the like real data like that's bad so
you need to be able to figure out some
way to not write to the real data as
you're doing your development and then
the the last piece is sort of like if
you're doing things that take a while to
run it can be really annoying to have
that happen as you're trying to iterate
quickly in your Dev environment so you
may want to like do things like down
sampling uh to be able to to iterate
quickly in Dev in a way that you don't
want to when you're going into
production obviously
so the the there's an r package called
config it's one of the like little loved
R packages it's one of my favorites
there actually I should have I should
have brought one of my colleagues made a
hex sticker for it as a fig on it which
I think is very clever uh but um it's a
great package it lets you sort of
differentiate environments in a variety
of ways and we'll we'll get into exactly
how that works but the basic idea is as
usual there is a yaml file right going
to production is just like yaml it's
just yaml all the way down it's just
yaml on yaml on yaml so you take some
yaml and you like you load the yaml into
your R session and that's how you do
config great cool we'll we'll get a
little more into that in a minute so the
second thing you need then is a
mechanism right you have your three
environments and you need a mechanism to
go from one environment to the other to
the other right and so the the broad
class of mechanisms obviously is
something called CI CD continuous
integration continuous deployment you've
almost certainly heard of it some of you
uh may have heard of it and it sounds
extremely intimidating it is not so bad
I promise
um and in particular today I'm going to
be talking a little bit about GitHub
actions which is one cicd tool it's I
like it because it's really easy to use
if you use GitHub it's already right
there but there are lots of other
options like gitlab Azure devops Jenkins
all those are completely valid and work
quite similarly so I believe all of them
are also yaml it's yaml all the way down
um so like how does CI CD work you have
like your CI CD stuff and it's watching
your git repo right it's watching for
things to happen right those are
triggers when those things get triggered
then like it goes off and does
something right and we'll get into what
exactly that means but usually that
something is either automated testing or
a promotion from one place to another
right those are usually the two things
that are going to happen
um when you when your CI CD pipeline is
is triggered
okay now we're just gonna show off some
of this so I'm gonna go to and uh the
Wi-Fi's been a little spotty so uh YOLO
here we go
um this is a a document that I've got
I'm going to render it it is a quarto
doc
um which I believe have been coming up a
lot today because they're great oh
that's been something interesting
as I said yolo
um let's see if this dock is here
and it is so this is a little report
based on the Palmer Penguins data set if
any of you notice just a little toy data
set in in R and so what you'll notice is
that uh right up here right this is the
dev configuration that I'm using right
that's just like something I manually
put in there it's not like Auto auto
generated and it uses 166 data points if
any of you familiar with polymer
Penguins this is half the data set right
so I've down sampled obviously on a data
set with 300 and whatever 22 data points
you don't need to down sample but you
get the idea
um but you know this is just on my
machine this is on on right localhost
this is on my laptop I cannot show this
to you if I unless I like walk my laptop
over to you so if I want to share this
um there are a couple of options there
are many options right I'm gonna today
we're gonna use something called quarto
Pub if any of you haven't played with it
it is a place where you can host public
quarto documents for free
um so that's pretty cool resource if you
if you didn't know about it a little bit
like shiny apps all but like the shiny
apps there's a page here there's no page
here for quarter pub at least not yet
um and so this is the test version of my
app you can tell because it says it is
the test version uh and because it has
this great slug that includes test in
the name
um and so that's that's cool right here
I'm using the full data set 333 data
points and then I've got the prod
version which is exactly the same other
than the fact that it was rendered like
30 seconds later
um and that it's at the prod URL right
so and this is this is actually really
important that like test and prod should
look really similar right you want as
few differences as possible between test
and prod because very often the reason
the dashboard goes down is differences
between test and prod so when you try to
do that promotion
everything broke right so you want to
really minimize those differences as
much as possible
um okay so let's make a change let's
let's oops I don't need to open Zoom
that's not what I'm doing right now
um let's make a change here
um who has a favorite ggplot theme other
than minimal since we're using minimal
black and white I figured we were going
there all right so uh let's check out a
new Branch we're going to call it theme
for our new theme we're going to commit
this new theme change to new theme new
theme
theme
new theme typing in front of a crowd
folks uh so I'm going to commit that
um oh gotta hit the check mark new theme
commit
and push
terminal
okay so now this is getting pushed and
this is where we are living on the edge
because the Wi-Fi is spotty
yeah that's being slow okay so I'll show
off what would happen if we got to get
um so here is my git repository and I'll
keep an eye on it in case that that uh
shows up because I would like to show
you what it looks like
you know no good
no okay well what would happen is I go
ahead and make a pull request and when I
made the pull request this action would
kick off right it would start doing
things which is is pretty cool
um I'll show you one that that rendered
already so this is a job that ran a
little while ago uh it takes about two
minutes to run the job which is I think
pretty good right it's longer than I
want to show you during a 10 minute
during a 20 minute talk uh but really
not very long in the in the scheme of
like I'm trying to promote this into
into test and you can see it does a
bunch of different things right it sets
up the job it checks out the repository
it installs quarter right so like you
can think of it starting in totally like
a bear server I gotta set up quarto I
got a set of R I gotta install my R
packages I have to set up something so
that it knows where to publish to and
then it's going to render and publish
and uh if you I believe it will tell us
here where it's publishing to you right
so this published the test report that
we looked at just a minute ago let's see
if uh this has recovered oh it did not
it Just timed out
oh well
um
so uh uh so this this process pushed up
to my test uh test report
um
so how like so so okay so now we've
understood what we've done so far right
we had our our local change we made we
changed the theme uh we were going to
push that up to the test uh Branch it
was going to do our testing
um you would have seen and you would
have loved that after the test ran we
could have merged it and we merged it it
was going to run another set of GitHub
actions to push it to the the prod
Branch right so that's like a pretty
straightforward
um set of things but like how does it
know how to do all that how is that what
happens
that's what we're going to get into for
the last eight minutes
okay so first let's look at what's going
on here uh with the config package
remember I said like config it's just a
bunch of yaml
um but we want to use it inside our R
code right I used it here to down sample
so you can see I've got this config
config get right and when I do that it
loads up
this config object
and you can see that that is just right
like uh it's a bunch of variables it's
just it's just a bunch of our
um entities right so it's a list named
list
um and so that that's pretty useful so
now I can just use that in my code so
for example here where I'm slicing out
part of the data right I'm taking half
of it in some cases pulling another and
then I have like the config name and
that sort of thing so how again how does
it know to do this well I've got my
handy yaml file it's yaml all the way
down
so I've got in in the yaml file there
are three definitions of environments
there's default test and prod
corresponding to Dev test and prod in
config they use the term default because
that's sort of a fallback right if it's
not specified elsewhere and you can see
that in the default in the dev Place uh
I sample down to a half
of the data set I've also got it
configured so that that goes to the test
version of the report right uh if I were
to go to the test configuration right
there I go up to a full you know one
right all of the sample uh and then in
the prod version I add going to the
production version of the the report so
how does config know which which package
to pick up well when I do config
config get right what this does is it
looks at an environment variable it's in
my environment if you if you haven't
spent a lot of time playing around with
environment variables they're like a
really crucial part
of how configuring multiple environments
work right like that is how things that
are running know where they are is by
the environment variables that are set
around them so what I'm going to do is
here I'll manually just just to show you
sys.set and
uh and we'll set the the uh variable
uses by default is our config active
and I'm going to set it to be test so
now when I set our config active to be
test and I'm going to run config get
again you can see now I'm picking up the
test config right you can see my sample
fraction has updated to one and so it's
just right if we think back about our
yaml
it's now selecting this middle block
based on that environment variable that
I had that is called test that's how
config works like that's the whole thing
it loads variables from a yaml file
depending on what on the value of an
environment variable it's like super
simple but really powerful if you have
multiple environments and want different
things to be true in each environment
one other nice thing you can actually do
is inside your config file you can
actually run our code as well right so
these are all just like values that I'm
typing here but if there's something you
need to do that's a little more complex
you can actually run our code inside
your config I don't recommend it do
anything complicated but it you know
sometimes it's useful
um to do other kinds of things like for
example sometimes you want to have a
password that gets passed through but
not appear in your config file right you
could do a get the password from an
environment variable and pass it right
through inside your code
okay so that's the config piece of this
right that's the dividing up the the
environments now the GitHub part so by
convention in the dot GitHub workflows
folder is where my GitHub actions go and
again it's just yaml yeah I'm all the
way down uh and so what you'll see is if
you look in this in this uh yaml file
it's all the things right if you
remember here this is all the big
headers right set of quarto install R
install our package dependencies
these are those steps they're just
defined here right that's all this does
is it defines those steps and what it
does is it can use other actions that
people have pre-defined for me right I
can use the actions check out a
repository action I can use the quarto
dev right that both GitHub and
Standalone people can Define actions so
the quarto developers have defined a
setup Porto action the rlib group has
defined a setup R action and it actually
allows me to provide a variable right
what version do I want
um I can also just run arbitrary code
right so uh I think I think Mark right
you were talking about running our
script right they can run our script
here right through through GitHub
actions by just telling it to run that
that R script
um so that's really useful so that's
that's what this action does now how
does it know right again this is the
test one
it knows it's the test one because I
just have it set an environment variable
here right you can define environment
variables inside the definitions for
your GitHub actions flows it works
really nicely like that and the last
piece is when does this run
so this runs on a pull request when it
opens or reopens which is right that's
what
that's what you would have seen if the
Wi-Fi were were being a little nicer uh
you would have seen that when I opened a
pull request uh the GitHub action
checked off right away and that's that's
my testing workflow this is also a
really common workflow if you're doing
things like linting your code right you
put that in here uh doing things like
running test Suites really great to put
in in a in a pull request triggered
action
and then there's there's another action
right this one is identical I will tell
you you can look through if you want to
but the only difference here is that
it's using the prod config
and it runs actually on a push to the
main branch right and uh a a completed
merge is a push to the main branch right
so that's actually what it's really
going to be triggered on
um you can do more complex things like
nesting them with variables but the
syntax gets kind of complicated and I
didn't want to have to explain the
syntax nor actually figure it out uh for
myself so uh you can do that but I just
duplicated the the same action twice
um just to show you a little bit of what
the these actions look like so if you
look for example this is the rlib
actions setup our action you can see
they Define all of these various
variables I'll zoom in a little bit but
you can see like the they give you the r
version you can use you can you know set
the number of CPUs all these kinds of
things you can set and they just sort of
list them right in in the help for the
the
um
for that uh action
um
I don't think this pushed at this point
but let's double check maybe we can show
it real quick no still not pushing oh
well
um
great so uh that was mostly what I
wanted to show you today so uh just to
recap a little bit of where we've been
okay
so uh the bottom line use config and
environment variables to differentiate
your different environments right one
from the other
um use git to manage when things move
right the trigger is a get branching
strategy and so like I said back towards
the beginning right having good git
practices is kind of a prerequisite for
this or at least something you should do
along with this sometimes I see people
where this is actually a really good
motivation to set up get good get
practice right like if if your get
practices only matter because you're
like we're gonna do good it's like kind
of hard to care but if it's like do good
get or else you're gonna break the CI CD
that that's a much stronger motivator
sometimes this can actually really go
along nicely if you're trying to get
people to use git in a in a more
powerful and intentional way and then
use CI CD uh GitHub actions to do
promotion mechanics
um since I do work for positive I would
be remiss if I didn't just say that uh
pause it I'm so used to saying our
studio it's very hard to change my my
language it's been really difficult
um posit connect can do parts of this
for you right uh posit can connect can
do the thing where it watches the git
repo and picks up the changes for you so
you don't have to have a GitHub action
that's personally my favorite feature of
connect is that it can do that part for
you
um the other thing I will share is if
you thought this was cool and you were
interested in this I am writing a book
uh it's called devops for data science
it is drafted uh the writing is still
rough but the entire book exists it's
online at do4ds.com and if you're extra
double interested John Harmon who maybe
is watching online uh and has been
mentioned a number of times is actually
running a book club where some folks are
reading it so if you're interested you
can reach out to John and I'm sure they
would be happy to have another couple
people in their book club
um thank you very much everybody